for the third target of the season 4
manhunt
we come up against a rogue agent going
for the call sign
magnus what information will we find
towards locating the division's second
wave
acting commander felau
dustin xavier codename magnus grew up in
atlanta
georgia a true patriot at heart he went
on to join the us military
to do his part in fighting for and
protecting his country
during his second tour in afghanistan
his unit was struck by an improvised
explosive device
and they were ambushed shortly after
after showing extraordinary heroism
during this incident
he later received the valorous unit
award
it was at this point that he was
approached by the shd and recruited
shortly thereafter
however it wasn't long before he started
questioning how well prepared the
division was
with their mission
or xavier or javier egg savior
thanks it annoys me when people don't
know how to say lao but have no problem
with maguire mcmahon
o'shea and kavanaugh fisher schneider
mueller might have something to say
about that your cr was german right
very third generation kept assisting his
family was never nazi's which
you know the more you protest the more
likely you are exactly that thing
boys let's show the lady what she's won
your unit in afghanistan
yeah we got hit by an ied
it happens any residual trauma just the
normal
got to make sure it wasn't for nothing
that's how they got me
just in case we need you to join us just
in case
most likely you'll never be activated
but just in case
you survived the worst you could handle
this no one can handle this
we're just here to minimize the damage
and hope there's something left when
we're through
and if there isn't we will be the ones
to rebuild it
looking forward to working with you
magnus
he came to the conclusion that the
recruitment process was more about
getting numbers
and ticking boxes rather than being
adequately prepared
for such an event to occur and this was
only further supported when he witnessed
the lack of equipment and resources
allocated to agents and how hugely
insufficient it was to handle the crisis
at hand
not long after his activation in
washington dc magnus was approached by
baden schaefer
you get it we're the same you're a
patriot
you served your country same as me we've
seen what can happen when a weak leader
rises to power we have
and i know that we can't rely on the
government to save us
this thing moves too fast you have to be
agile
the wheels of government rule too slowly
for something like this they're trying
to use a scalpel
when what we need is a sledgehammer i
can be that hammer
magnus immediately recognized an
individual with the same drive
and objectives as himself someone who
only wanted what was best for the
country
so he would go on to join with the black
tusk
magnus would later be assigned to
feylau's unit of rogue agents
but his demeanor didn't exactly have him
fitting in with the rest of the team
magnus sub viper
gross what i just said sup
yeah i know what sup means hey hey you
don't mean nothing
unless you wanted to mean something
gross hey
you don't have to be like that and you
don't have to be a disgusting human
being but here we are
i hope you get eclipsed that's
[ __ ] up i just said sup and you wish
that keener [ __ ] on me
you're cold viper i thought we were
friends
being a soldier was all he knew he was
just there to do a job
and work with the side that he believed
had the country's best interests at
heart
he wasn't there to prove himself he
hadn't been impacted by the failure of
the government or the shd
he hadn't witnessed tragedy or lost
anyone close to him as a result
he simply found a team that he saw was
more aligned with his goals
and were better equipped to handle it
however some of the ways he approached
certain aspects of the organization
wasn't necessarily appreciated by his
colleagues
it just couldn't seem to comprehend that
he wasn't in the military anymore
and his new comrades from vastly
different backgrounds
didn't seem to be overly fond of his
banter and the ideas that he brought to
the table
i don't know why you keep pitching me
your dumbass ideas
my ideas are dumb who better than the
people in the field
the ones using the gear to tell you what
they want and need out of the gear
fine okay so like stay with me
think about it think about what give me
a second
okay picture it you're out in the field
you've got hostiles on your right and
left yeah
so it's a tuesday you see an opportunity
to run and slide into cutting
but there's mud yeah some are in dc
lots of mud got it and you've only got
one pair of pants
so what do you want what if your knee
pads had quick depletion
in hip guards you want my sister
to make knee pads that have quick deploy
sliding shin and hip guards
so you don't have to wash mud off your
pants yeah
think how awesome that would be yeah
i'm not calling her for that
when the time came magnus set forth
executing his part in the operation
taking his unit of btsu he started
capturing locations of interest
in the western districts of washington
dc multiple sites were captured in
downtown west
constitution hall and east end
but as has happened time and time again
the division were there to stop the
rogue advances
the shd were able to quickly and
efficiently remove any trace of his
movements in dc
and eventually caught up to him
taken by surprise he put up a valiant
fight
but was no match for the agents
there's really not so much we can talk
about with magnus i feel as though
everything we saw pretty much sums him
up
brave soldier loves his country
recruited by the shd
didn't like what he saw and decided to
instead follow someone who had similar
goals to himself
in turn turning rogue and was then
hunted by the division and
eliminated to be clear that probably
sums up all of the seasons in manhunts
up until now
but the majority have had something
extra to add to the overall story even
if it was just about what they had
witnessed
that had them turning rogue in the first
place but not magnus
he basically just chose to switch sides
he's probably best summed up as another
example of the terrible recruitment
system that the shd has been using
although an experienced and heroic
soldier he didn't seem to have the
qualities
to work and lead in a situation where
there would be little to no support from
the outside
and at the first opportunity where a
charismatic and strong leader approached
him
he was quick to follow and change sides
anyway i hope you've enjoyed the summary
the next one will give us access to fey
lau
so will hopefully give us some insight
into the future of where the division
story is going
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch you in the next
one cheers
[Music]
uh